this is so wonderful because um you get
to this point when you're doing a
question they've never seen it before so
you like this is how you do it and you
have to think to convince yourself yes
no this is definitely the right approach
I can convince myself that I've gone
about this the right way now again it's
very intimidating just when you look at
okay so just take it on and see if you
can work it down to science the first
thing I'm going to do is look at that
bit in the middle every this video okay
so I'm going to consider just that guy
now by the way can I just make a little
point of here there's no reason why I
mean you can there's no reason why I
have to write books all three parts of
this inequality all like every single
time for all of your work there's no
reason why you don't have to but I'm
just going to work on this thing for a
little while and then I'm gonna replace
what I get here inside there okay so I'm
going to consider whatever that
expression expression is so I'm going to
work with this thing you see what I
could do with it okay now I've said one
of the most useful things you can do the
whole reason we explored rectangular and
polar form is because each has induced
I'm gonna rewrite in X plus iy form and
it's going to look like this
that's what it looks like now this is
just arithmetic it's just arithmetic I
want to expand this so that I can see
which parts are real and which parts are
not okay so you can in fact see if you
have a look at this right I don't even
need to write the whole expansion out do
i right you've got a binomial times
another binomial right but exactly half
of the terms you get out of these four
are gonna be real do you agree with that
look this to here right if I want though
if I'm really interested in the real
part then I'm only interested in the two
and the X the two real bits together
right this real part this imaginary part
they're going to be another use to me
does that make sense in the same way
when you combine two imaginary numbers
and multiply those don't color what
happens to the eyes
they've become real right they become so
in other words that they kind of cancel
out maybe cancer even though I sometimes
say that maybe not the best phrase
because in fact they do leave something
good that they leave negative one right
so those two other bits I'm also
interested so I'm just going to go
straight to those right to X that's
going to be real and what else do I get
plus three why don't I write because
those eyes are going to change my sign
that's it
so therefore the the reason I'm really
interested in is this now some of you I
need you to flex your to unit an
extension one brains because that's the
part that confuses you right so what
does this look like if I were to ask you
to graph this
what does that look like well this may
go to the right of negative two and
you're to the left of three and then
there's some stuff you have to work out
in the batteries in other words what I
mean is I want X to be greater than
negative two and simultaneously I want X
to be less than or equal to three
I can do each of those independently
then I just want both of them right so
what does this thing look like well one
side six less than two x plus three what
do you remember there's a trick I taught
you for graphing straight lines really
quickly I can put this into two
intercept form right so I'm going to
divide everything by six
that won't leave me with one over here
what's this going to be X on three and
why on - okay so I've got my x and
y-intercepts and then I've got one is
less than that so just gonna work out
which side I'm on
okay then I say and and as well as that
I've got to have this bit right is this
makes sense so again I'm going to put it
into two it is it for divide through by
12 which leaves me with X on and Y on
awesome right now just cut to the chase
what is this thing gonna look like
when you draw these two lines here's
this one three and two so one two three
one two there you go there's that line
you notice I've drawn it solid okay
because that's going to be part of the
inequality this line over here one two
three four five six one two three four
this one's going to be dotted right now
you should be able to work out I'm
actually going to be at the outsides on
the inside so where am I gonna be I'm
gonna be in the middle would be in the
middle of this region you now understand
one more thing to this suppose I said I
want more than this I also want you to
satisfy this maybe one jot this down
so this is like my base region this is
my base region and now I'm going to
restrict it a little bit hmm
Oh with this mitt okay there's gonna be
a restriction on quadrants right here's
one way you can think about it the real
part is just the imaginary part is just
Y so what you want is your Exeter wise
when they are multiplied together
they're positive now there's an easy way
to get that if x and y are both positive
that's cool
that's the first quadrant up here isn't
it there's another way you can do it
though right if they're both negative
you'll still get a positive product but
as you can see that to be relevant to
this particular question because no part
of the region is in there anyway okay so
how would I then restrict this a bit
further on board to look like yeah I'm
gonna like wipe out this part in here on
time right
have a look carefully what kind of
boundaries am I gonna have they're gonna
be dotted or not dotted they're gonna be
not done a we saw nothing so I'm gonna
write color this guy is going to be
solid here but be careful solid open
I've been in coach do you see why
because this whole bottom line is not
part of the region okay and then the
same thing down here solid and then
weapon yeah that's exactly what it